bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler d'un smartphone que j'avais dans
les tiroirs depuis un petit moment que
j'ai testé à berlin a mis fin en
septembre dernier alors je sais ça va se
dégager un petit moment
je voudrais pas pareil tout de suite
j'ai gardé un peu sous le coude mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il est l'heure d'en
parler on va parler du motorola loto
[Musique]
salut à tous voici une souris je vous
parle de technologie je vous parle de
hightex des guides des tutos des infos
des astuces des conseils pour la high
tech
si vous êtes intéressé je vous invite à
messein jolie pouces et surtout à vous
abonner
je dois parler du nouveau smartphone de
motorola le moto x 4 que j'ai en ma
possession
quel produit qui est plutôt sympa un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme à moins de
400 euros qui a des avantages qui est un
design est sympa mais on va regarder ça
tout de suite ensemble
le moto 2 4 c'est vraiment le produit
qui la concurrence est le samsung galaxy
à 5 alors le a5 c'est un produit qui est
vraiment très bien qu'il ya une bonne
autonomie qui a deux bons appareils
photo à l'avant à l'arrière et qu'un
écran super amoled alors effectivement
ce téléphone la nappe à un écran super
amoled
on est sur du lcd on va pas se comparer
forcément à samsung mais quand on arrive
dans cette gamme de prix pour faire des
choix on va pas acheter tous les
smartphones parce que l'un cet avantage
de la et l'autre à celui là ou alors à
ce moment là bas vous êtes notre
abonnement plusieurs villes et si vous
êtes comme tout un chacun comme moi
quelqu'un normal c'est un téléphone qui
est très simple alors on va regarder la
fiche technique et puis à la forme à ras
des cils vaut le coup puisqu'il faut
l'acheter rime si vous intéresse
d'ailleurs je voulais un gars dans la
description est de 8 à 10 tonnes qui
coule est il à une dalle 5.2 full hd
1920 par 1080 un lcd inocule 68% de la
face avant
les contrastes sont au rendez vous et la
luminosité est sympa c'est un produit
qui se tient qui a un écran de qualité
à l'arrière il a deux objectifs il est
d'ailleurs un gros bloc qui détache un
petit peu d'un point de vue design et
sandra parle juste après et double
cabine arrière avec un 12 mégapixels
autofocus avec une ouverture le 2.0 et
un 8 mégapixels avec l'ouverture en 2.2
avec un grand-angle stocks ont
effectivement d'avoir soit des photos je
dirais un peu classique avec un angle
relativement classique et normale et un
grand angle face fait aujourd'hui
énormément sur les nouveaux smartphones
nous rendu photo assez sympa très lisse
et lorsque vous avez une bonne lumière
des cons baisse en luminosité
on perd forcément qualité moins génial
après une fois de plus on est sur un
produit qui coûte quand même moins de
400 euros à l'avant vous avez une caméra
de saïfi en 16 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de l'objectif en 2.0 les sept
filles sont correct bonne qualité c'est
honnête ça marche il a un processeur
snapdragon 630 octas core cadencé à 2,2
ghz 3 giga de ram et 64 gb de stockage
qu'on peut monter jusqu'à 2 tera donc ça
s'est vraiment bien lorsque vous voulez
stocker beaucoup de vidéos beaucoup de
musique
beaucoup de photos beaucoup de souvenirs
pour tous de votre vie dans le téléphone
c'est bien ça marche côté design à
l'avant il a rien d'exceptionnel des
grandes barres en haut et en bas
d'ailleurs un capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui est passé sous l'écran et
qui marche bien un cadre en aluminium
anodisé est maintenant temps de trouver
quelque chose d'un petit peu original il
faut regarder du côté du dos folie qui
fait tout en métal qui est vraiment très
sympa qui a un côté vraiment très
précieux vraiment premium le logo de
motorola qui est très sympa carrière le
reconnaître qu'un alien qui est vraiment
bien pensé au niveau de la caméra
arrière c'est un smartphone qui était
très sympa très agréable de prise en
main un dos en verre qui est élégant
mettriez sa licence et ça c'est pas
génial
il ya un aspect 3d que le côté élégant à
côté bien dessiné effectivement on n'est
pas sur les très grands écrans bord à
bord mais ça reste quand même un
smartphone qui est un très élégant
vous avez votre bouton pour l'allumer
ici le bouton pour monter et pour
baisser le volume
ici une prise jack et le port pour
l'aliment côté batterie vous avez une
batterie ion 3000 milliampères heures
vous allez pouvoir tenir facilement la
journée complète en utilisation normale
hors ceux utilisés comme un sauvage tout
en dessous fatalement ça va consommer
plus mais si utilisé normalement comme
monsieur madame tout le monde
ça marche très bien c'était parfaitement
d'affaires et un chargement hyper rapide
que j'appelle le turbo powers chargé on
retrouve deux usb type c est une
certification ib 68 c'est un produit
complètement résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière avec une certification ip68
alors vous amusez pas à plonger à faire
grand blake mais par contre il peut
aller dans l'eau il ne craint
à part les éclaboussures ni la poussière
donc ça c'est vraiment aussi un point
positif c'est un produit qui tourne sous
android 7 points 1 point en ouganda et
surtout il est proposé à 379 euros par
motorola et la honte que sur amazon à
358 euros
alors vous allez liens dans la
description pour moi les plus de ce
produit c'est la robustesse c'est un
produit solide
le verre est sérieux alors j'ai pas dire
qu'il est incassable rien est incassable
et en termes de résistance à que châssis
en alu et le dos en verre qui écarte
bien vous pouvez l'emmener partout où
elle passe par tous un téléphone qui se
tient très bien
autre point positif l'autonomie c'est un
téléphone qui durent longtemps ça c'est
très bien maintenant
point négatif la photo qui est assez
moyenne en basse luminosité et puis
surtout les traces de doigts traces de
doigts à l'arrière ça c'est vraiment le
truc pour moi c'est rédhibitoire
parce que comme sur l'honneur notes et
même comme sur l'iphone disent tous ces
dos en verre sont très bien pour la
recharge dans l'induction saga rien à
dire l'écart n'est pas l'absolu mais
pour le reste c'est vrai que c'est bien
mais les trains de loi dessus c'est pas
génial vraiment est-ce qu'il faut
l'acheter
oui non et à qui est-ce qu'ils
s'adressent alors pour moi c'est un
téléphone qui est assez équilibré c'est
un téléphone qui est sérieux qui est
solide si vous voulez un produit qui
risquent pas de se casser demain qui va
pas être trop fragile qui a une bonne
autonomie qui fait des photos correctes
avec une bonne lumière bien évidemment
pour moi le motorola moto x 4 fait
parfaitement le job et vous pouvais
tranquille là dessus maintenant si vous
cherchez un bel écran si vous cherchez
du super amoled
il faut partir plutôt du côté du samsung
galaxy à 5 pour un petit peu ce qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui sur ce nouveau
produit de cheyrou taux relatifs à ce
que vous en pensez en commentaire est ce
que vous avez déjà vu un produit chez
motorola est ce que vous envisagez d'en
acquérir un nouveau qu'est ce que vous
concède ce produit est ce qu'il vaut
séduit oui ou non vous devez tout son
commentaire et on a un crédit vous
invite à laisser des jolies pousse à
vous abonner à fera toujours toujours et
toujours plus de contenu pour parler de
votre vie numérique
il ya très bientôt soyez sages portez
vous bien gros bisous et restez
connectés à skype grande grande surprise
dans les temps à venir
ciao
[Musique]